y ahora vamos a hablar acerca de las
varias
hables
aleatorias
historias y bueno la verdad es que no
estoy completamente segura de que este
nombre sea muy didáctico o sea porque la
palabra variable ya la usamos muchísimo
pero en otro contexto completamente
distinto o sea a poco no cuando te
hablan de una variable te acuerdas de
por no ser por ejemplo una ecuación que
dice 3 es igual a x + 5 donde lo que uno
tiene que hacer es despejar la variable
x para encontrar qué valor tiene que
tomar o por ejemplo cuando estamos en
geometría y tenemos que igual a 5 x + 7
donde bueno aquí si no tomamos en cuenta
de esta ecuación tenemos dos variables y
pues pueden tomar una infinidad de
valores pero están como que muy
relacionadas estas dos variables o sea
si en algún punto decidimos que x vale
tanto entonces eso implica que llévale
otra cosa bueno pero las variables
aleatorias no son como estas variables
las variables aleatorias
si son variables en el sentido de que
pueden tomar muchísimos valores
distintos que ahorita en este momento no
sabes cuánto vale pero son distintas de
las variables a las que estamos
acostumbrados porque nunca jamás vamos a
tratar de encontrar cuánto realmente
vale porque ahí va a ser como una
incógnita para nosotros porque en
realidad su valor generalmente es
aleatorio y bueno en cuestión de
notación generalmente digo no siempre
pero muchísimas veces se denota a las
variables aleatorias con letras
mayúsculas no con letras minúsculas como
estas y pues la forma más típica es una
letra x mayúscula aunque claro que
también se encuentran por ahí con yes y
hasta con pes minúsculas y muchas otras
cosas pero bueno en el fondo una
variable aleatoria más que ser como una
variable aritmética es una especie de
función del mundo de los sucesos
aleatorios a un número real por ejemplo
un suceso aleatorio puede ser si va a
llover mañana o no
y entonces vamos a poner por aquí llueve
mañana
me llena
entonces puede llover mañana o puede no
llover mañana no
v
mañana aunque entonces si queremos usar
esta x para asociar cosas aleatorias
como si va a llover mañana o no va a
llover mañana lo que hacemos es crear
una función de tal forma que si llueve
mañana le asociamos no sé digamos un 1 y
si no llueve mañana le asociamos un 0 ok
de hecho lo podemos escribir como x d
llueve mañana
[Música]
igual a 1 y x d no llueve mañana igual a
0 ok hay que recordar que esta x en
lugar de ser una variable como las que
estábamos acostumbrados en el álgebra
geometría de todas esas cosas más que
nada es una función que manda a eventos
aleatorios a números reales y bueno en
realidad no teníamos que escoger a uno y
hacer o no se hace aquí podríamos haber
puesto 91
1000 o algo así y bueno aquí no sabemos
qué valor va a tomar esta equis no
sabemos si va a tomar el valor de 91 o
de 1000 esto solo lo vamos a saber hasta
mañana más o menos podemos llegar a
tener alguna idea de con qué
probabilidad va a tomar cada uno de
estos valores pero el valor de x todavía
no está determinado y no hay nada que
podamos hacer para determinarlo aunque
no lo podemos despejar ni nada por el
estilo seguro sería muy bueno ver muchos
más ejemplos de variables aleatorias
entonces vamos a hacer más espacio y
bueno de hecho no tenemos que sacar
variables aleatorias tan complicadas
pueden ser de lo más sencillas
por ejemplo la variable x puede ser
igual al número que sale hacia arriba
cuando tenemos un dado que el número
escrito escrito
en la cara la cara de arriba
d
dado que acabamos de tirar lanzado
podríamos ponerle la
y bueno de hecho no tiene que ser la
cara de arriba podría ser por ejemplo la
cara que esté mirando hacia el oeste y
si se fijan esta es una forma muy
sencilla de agarrar un suceso aleatorio
y asociar le un número a cada uno de los
posibles resultados a ver veamos otro
por ejemplo podemos poner x igual a 1 si
lanzamos una moneda y sale águila
[Música]
y águila pero si sale el sol aunque otra
vez cada volado es un experimento
aleatorio y lo que estamos haciendo con
esta variable aleatoria es a cada
resultado asociarle un número ahora
estamos viendo todo esto de las
variables aleatorias porque son muy
importantes muy útiles y son súper
necesarias para poder hablar de todo lo
que sigue o sea por ejemplo de funciones
de distribución de probabilidad y de la
esperanza y de muchas otras cosas que
vamos a ver después entonces qué bueno
que ya las definimos ahora lo que vamos
a hacer es empezar con las funciones de
distribución de probabilidad aunque
sabes que me faltó hacer una cosa muy
importante con esto de las variables
aleatorias y es que o sea tenemos a las
variables aleatorias
y estas se dividen en dos tipos las
variables aleatorias discretas discretas
y las variables aleatorias continuas con
ty más todos los ejemplos que hemos
visto hasta ahorita es de variables
aleatorias discretas porque hay digamos
un número finito de posibles valores que
puede tomar la variable aleatoria o sea
por ejemplo aquí la x puede tomar o un 1
o un 0 por aquí cuando tenemos que x es
igual a la cara que sale hacia arriba
cuando tenemos un dado pues el dado sólo
tiene 6 caras
entonces nuestra variable x puede tomar
uno de esos seis posibles valores y en
esta otra variable aleatoria pues
también puede tomar únicamente dos
valores o sea hay dos posibles
resultados que llueva mañana o que no
llueva mañana entonces x puede ser igual
a 91 o puede ser igual a 1000 pero no
puede ser igual a ningún otro número
así es que todas esas variables que
hemos visto son variables discretas
porque sólo pueden tomar una cantidad
finita de valores por otro lado las
variables continuas tienen una infinidad
de posibilidades
ok aquí podríamos pensar por ejemplo no
tienen que ser los números naturales
simplemente tiene que haber una cantidad
finita de valores que puede tomar pero
más o menos la estructura se parece y de
este lado el espacio de valores que
puede tomar la variable aleatoria
continua es más o menos parecido como a
la recta de los reales a ver un ejemplo
de una variable continua por ejemplo
pensemos en la cantidad la cantidad
exacta de lluvia que caerá mañana en
mililitros con todos los puntos
decimales a la derecha aquí la cantidad
exacta exacta de mililitros de lluvia
de lluvia
caerá mañana
esta si es una variable aleatoria
continua no o sea porque aquí no se
trata de si caerán 3.000 mililitros de
lluvia mañana ni de si caerán 3 mil y 1
mililitros de lluvia mañana o sea
queremos la cantidad exacta de
mililitros y no se podría hacer por
ejemplo que en realidad con todos los
moles y todo el asunto cayeran 3.000
puntos 5 mililitros de lluvia porque ahí
el chiste es que en medio de
cualesquiera dos números que queramos
tomar siempre hay otro número aquí en
medio que hay lo mismo entre estos dos
números siempre hay algún otro número
por acá y lo mismo pasa entre estos dos
números y entre éstos y entre éstos y
entre estos siempre hay un numerito por
acá y siempre puede ser que en lugar de
que caigan 3.000 mililitros de lluvia
mañana caiga una milésima de gota
y entonces en realidad la cantidad
exacta de lluvia esté por aquí en lugar
de por acá la diferencia entre las
variables discretas y las variables
continuas es que las discretas tienen un
número finito de valores que pueden
tomar y las continuas tienen un número
infinito y además vamos a ver que tienen
distintas funciones asociadas las dos
tienen funciones de distribución de
probabilidad pero por ejemplo las
variables aleatorias discretas tienen
una cosa que se llama función de masa de
probabilidad y las funciones continuas
tienen una función de densidad de
probabilidad aunque hay que son lo mismo
son análogas representan exactamente lo
mismo pero que tienen que ser distintas
por el tipo de valores que puede tomar
la variable aleatoria ok lo vamos a ver
muy pronto
así es que vamos a empezar por las
variables discretas que son todos los
ejemplos que vimos al principio del
vídeo donde solo se puede tomar una
cantidad finita de valores porque íbamos
a ver su
función de
más de probabilidad proba
bueno entonces tenemos la variable
aleatoria x y vamos a escoger la de los
datos que x es simplemente el número de
la cara
[Música]
que voltea que él
de hacia arriba hacia arriba después de
tirar un dado
pues
de tirar
dado ok entonces vamos a poner por aquí
el eje de las equis y en el eje de las
equis vamos a poner todos los posibles
valores que puede tomar la variable x
entonces el dado es un dado justo
qué significa eso de que sea justo es
que tiene números del 1 al 6 en cada una
de sus caras y que a la hora de tirarlo
cualquiera de las caras puede ser la que
salga hacia arriba con la misma
probabilidad aunque hay entonces x puede
tomar el valor de 1 2 3
4 5 o 6 y en el eje de las 10 este eje
vamos a colocar la probabilidad con la
que x toma cada uno de estos valores
así es que x toma el valor de uno si el
dado cae con el número uno mirando hacia
arriba y como es un dado justo la
probabilidad de que el dado caiga con el
uno hacia arriba es de un sexto
así es que aquí vamos a poner un sexto y
vemos que la probabilidad de que x sea
igual a 1 es exactamente un sexto ok lo
mismo pasa con el 2
entonces colocamos esto por aquí en
realidad quería que estuvieran a la
misma altura pero pues ya ni modo y lo
mismo pasa con cada uno de estos números
no porque el dado es justo entonces
todos tienen probabilidad
un sexto
sexto
un sexto y ahora sí un sexto bueno
acabamos de dibujar nuestra primera
función de masa de probabilidad muchos
la gráfica de esta forma aunque hay
otras personas que ponen cero en todos
lados y cuando llegan al valor que puede
tomar la variable aleatoria dejan un
ojito por acá y colocan el punto a la
altura de la probabilidad que entonces
nos quedaría así
y con esto por acá pero bueno eso es
nada más distintas formas de graficar
esta misma función que hay en realidad
esta función la podemos describir como
x es igual
un sexto si x es igual a 1
un sexto si x es igual a 2 como sexto si
x es igual a 3 un texto si x es igual a
4 un sexto si x es igual a 5 un sexto si
x es igual a 6 y 0 si x es cualquier
otra cosa
cualquier otro número aunque esta
función de mar que queda bueno entonces
esa fue la función de masa de
probabilidad de esta variable aleatoria
tenemos que ver más ejemplos a ver ahora
tenemos a la variable x igual a 1 si
sale águila si sale
águila águila en un volado con una
moneda justa y cero si sale el sol si
sale sol en ese volado con moneda justa
entonces su función de masa de
probabilidad función de masa de
probabilidad vamos a graficar la por
aquí está el eje de las equis en donde
ponemos los posibles valores de x que
son 0 y 1 y el eje de las che es por acá
donde ponemos la probabilidad con la que
x toma cada uno de estos valores bien
entonces como estamos tirando una moneda
ajuste la probabilidad de que no salga
águila en ese volado es un medio y
entonces como x es igual a 1 si sale
águila entonces la probabilidad de que x
sea igual a 1 es un medio
y medio y lo mismo la probabilidad de
que en ese volado salga un sol es un
medio así es que la probabilidad de que
x0 también es un medio y x no puede
tomar ningún otro valor
o sea que tome todos estos valores con
probabilidad cero así es que estamos
dibujando bien la gráfica toma el cero
con probabilidad un medio después todos
estos valores los toma con probabilidad
0 y en el 1 vuelve a saltar esta función
muchísimo y el resto de los números los
toma con probabilidad 0 entonces tenemos
aquí a la gráfica de la función de masa
de probabilidad de esta variable
aleatoria y vamos a ver más
a ver vamos a ver qué pasa si nosotros
tenemos una variable equis y sabemos que
x es igual al número que sale hacia
arriba a la hora de tirar un dado ok
pero en realidad no sabemos si ese dado
es justo o si fue cargado o si alguien
lo modificó de alguna forma lo único que
sabemos es cuál es su función de masa de
probabilidad aunque ya tenemos dibujada
por acá
y aquí está el 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 y tenemos
que la probabilidad con la que x es
igual a 1 es igual a un sexto sexto por
aquí también nos dicen que la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 2 es
cero ok
así es que nunca jamás sale un 2 cuando
tenemos esa edad y también podemos ver
que la probabilidad de que salga 3 4 o 5
es igual a un sexto
sin embargo la probabilidad de que no
salga un 6 está loquísimo pero está
altísima aunque ella es de dos sextos
así es que nos dan la función de masa de
probabilidad sabemos qué x es
exactamente igual al número que sale
hacia arriba entonces podemos
preguntarnos qué demonios está pasando
aquí y bueno si lo pensamos tantito nos
puede empezar a aparecer muy claro que
alguien tomó un dado justo y dibujo
otros cuatro puntitos en el lado del dos
para que pareciera un 6 eso explicaría
todo no o sea porque ahora cada que en
el dado justo aparecería un 2 ahora
aparece un 6 y entonces este pedazo de
probabilidad que le correspondía al 2
fue trasladado al número 6 okey porque
ahora cada vez que viera salir un 2 nos
sale un 6 entonces si no salía 6 con
probabilidad un sexto
a eso ahora le tenemos que sumar la
probabilidad de que en realidad nos haya
salido un 2 pero que nuestra variable x
ahora lo esté tomando como un 6 porque
pues abre el número escrito es un 6 en
lugar de un 2 y bueno el gran chiste de
las funciones de masa de probabilidad es
que te permiten ver muy rápidamente cómo
se distribuye la probabilidad aunque
fácilmente si yo te pregunto ahorita
cuál es la probabilidad de que x sea
igual a 6 pues tú fácilmente puedes ver
esta gráfica y decir a la probabilidad
de que x sea igual a 6 nos vamos al 6
nos fijamos a qué altura está el puntito
y a esta altura dos sextos entonces la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 6
es dos sextos bueno y ahora cuál es la
probabilidad de que x sea mayor o igual
a 5 entonces lo que nos estamos
preguntando es cuál es la probabilidad
de que la variable caiga de aquí para la
derecha aunque incluyendo al 5 entonces
lo que tenemos que hacer es humedad
todas estas probabilidades cuál es la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 5 pues
es un sexto un sexto más la probabilidad
de que x sea igual a 5.5 que pues es 0 y
así con todos estos ceros más la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 6 que
es dos sextos dos sextos que finalmente
es igual a tres sextos y bueno esta
gráfica también lo podemos poner así
y algo que tenemos que notar aquí es que
esta gráfica es distinta a las otras dos
que habíamos dibujado que no todos los
puntitos están a la misma altura cierto
como en las otras dos que habíamos
dibujado así es que pues esta es una
función de masa de probabilidad más
interesante
en estas otras funciones de masa de
probabilidad
si te fijas la masa se distribuye
uniformemente y por eso dice que aquí
hay una distribución uniforme aunque hay
una distribución uniforme de la
probabilidad porque todos están a la
misma altura entonces como que la
probabilidad está distribuida
uniformemente bueno lo que vamos a hacer
en los próximos vídeos es salirnos de
estas variables discretas vamos a
empezar a ver variables continuas y
vamos a ver las funciones de densidad de
probabilidad que es lo mismo que la
función de masa de probabilidad nada más
que ahora para variables discretas donde
en lugar de hacer funciones tan
sencillas como éstas pues podemos tener
ondas y cosas así que es repito son
exactamente análogas solo que a veces
más complicadas y a veces mucho más
fáciles de manejar pero bueno después de
ver eso de las funciones de densidad de
probabilidad para las variables
aleatorias continuas vamos a regresar a
las variables discretas a ver todas esas
distribuciones de la prueba
que aparecen muy comúnmente en la
naturaleza una de ellas ya la vimos es
justo esta que es la distribución
uniforme pero también vamos a ver la
distribución binomial la distribución
por acción y luego distribuciones
continuas como la distribución normal
que a veces le llaman jawzjan y un
montón de otras cosas muy interesantes y
muy útiles entonces te veo pronto